welcome to the new icarly they're
married they have kids
they're all grown up so what can we
expect from the icarly reboot
since icarly ended the cast have gone in
all sorts of different directions with
their careers and personal lives
which cast member is now a big shot
journalist
how about who has two kids of their own
today
we're covering where they've been and
what we can expect from them in the new
icarly reboot
how'd you know yes how did you know
it's been nearly 10 years since icarly
was on our screens and with the new
reboot coming soon
we're experiencing some serious
nostalgia
yes so what exactly has the cast been up
to since then
let's start with carly aka miranda
cosgrove
after the show wrapped and cosgrove was
recognized as one of the
highest paid child actresses in the
guinness world records book in 2012
she actually took a bit of a step back
from acting and hit the books
we haven't even gotten to that chapter
yet the actress attended the university
of southern california
and while she was there cosgrove changed
her major
three times before finally settling on a
psychology degree i do
i just i've the only thing is i don't
live on campus while she did want to
spend time on her studies
the acting bug was still very much a
part of her and a major reason
why she actually chose to stay in la so
she could continue to work in the
industry
and that is what she did since she ended
up voicing margot for the first
despicable me movie when she was in
university
you're never gonna be my dad she's
appeared in various tv movies and
episodic shows over the years as well
how about her best friend sam aka
jeanette mccurdy
she's damn sam-i-am the charismatic
actress is multi-talented and has been
doing lots of directing and writing
including pieces published by the wall
street journal and the huffington post
while she has stepped back from
television acting before the pandemic
mccurdy had written and performed in a
one-woman show in la that was meant to
have more performances but of course
wound up being cancelled due to public
health regulations
hopefully she'll be able to hit the
stage again soon enough
i didn't know that was gonna be here one
of the actors whose life has changed
pretty drastically is nathan kress or as
we like to remember him
freddy benson it's crazy to think that
this former child
actor is now married and has two
children of his own
we wonder if his kids are fans of the
original icarly
crest married fellow actor and stunt
performer london moore in 2015
and has continued to work in the
industry with roles in various films and
some directing credits as well
press actually directed 11 henry danger
episodes
when he isn't busy directing performing
or playing with his adorable kids
cress can be found podcasting with
fellow actor brett davern
the two are the hosts of radioactive
dads
let's get out of here where has jerry
trainer been
well he's continued to act and has
actually appeared in tons of nickelodeon
shows
like henry danger and wendell and vinnie
gibby
what are you doing my thing as for gibby
actor noah monk actually almost had his
own spin-off series
a gibby led pilot was made but
ultimately it didn't get picked up
monk continues to act but as of late
he's been putting his energy into music
production
most recently he's been creating music
under the name
sad world beats talk about talent
i told you i'd get revenge then of
course there's reed alexander
or as we like to call him neville
alexander is probably the actor whose
career has changed the most over the
past few years since
he isn't even in the entertainment
industry now the former child actor
continued to act a bit after icarly but
then his passions took him to nyu
followed by columbia university where he
got a master's degree
so where exactly is he now reed
alexander is a big
shot journalist working as a wall street
reporter for business insider
when he isn't busy talking about
finances it seems he does a lot of
traveling to beautiful places
all over the world at least according to
his instagram
jeanette mccurdy is remembered as a
beloved child star who had a career
many young adults would dream of but the
fact is
it was never really her dream this is
actually one of the main reasons we
won't be seeing her reprise her role as
sam in the icarly reboot
since the show ended mccurdy has opened
up about the fact that it was actually
her mother who put her in the industry
when she was a child to help the family
financially and within a few years
mccurdy had found great success and her
career was what kept her family afloat
this was a pretty selfless act and not
to mention a huge responsibility for
anyone
especially someone so young her work as
an actor became a necessity for her
family's livelihood so
she stuck with it but the truth is
mccurdy was struggling
after her mother passed away the actress
made a big life change
she decided to step back from the
industry even after being told
she was crazy to walk away from such
success
however mccurdy ultimately wasn't happy
and hadn't been for quite some time
sadly she doesn't even look back on the
role that shot her to success fondly
she'd been quite embarrassed playing sam
for years and felt
really unfulfilled but since it was how
she was supporting her family the actor
felt stuck
it's no surprise to learn that she
struggled with ocd as a child
eating disorders throughout her career
and substance abuse after her mother
passed
which she was going through was
seriously rough when she starred in her
own show
sam and cat with ariana grande things
only got worse when mccurdy refused to
show up to a nickelodeon awards night
and criticized the studio for allegedly
underpaying her in comparison to what
grande was making
while she won't be appearing in the
reboot her creativity
hasn't stopped as she's ventured into
writing directing music
and seems to be much happier and more
comfortable with her life now
since she was such a major part of the
original series how will they
acknowledge her in the reboot
i think they're clear according to
miranda cosgrove their relationship is
discussed in the pilot
and the character is mentioned
throughout the season while we love to
see mccurdy take on the role again
it's nice to see that she's doing what's
best for her now
not only will we be missing sam in the
reboot does it
there will also be no gibby it seems
that actor noah monk has moved on from
the project himself as well
in a 2017 interview the actor explained
that he had a bit of a strange
relationship to the character and his
experience
wasn't the best so he just wanted to
move on from the role
a rep on twitter confirmed that monk had
indeed been approached about the reboot
but
since he doesn't appear in the trailer
it seems that the new icarly will be
without sam and gibby
while we are missing a couple of the
original characters the icarly reboot
will still be serving up some
classic characters as well as a host of
new ones to round out the cast
jerry trainor is back as spencer as is
nathan cress as freddy
while they are the same characters
they're far more grown up in this reboot
with talk of dating drinking
children you know adult stuff so we done
here
we have a feeling the show will be
perfect for all of us who grew up
watching the show when we were younger
these aren't the child performers we
once knew oh this is so exciting
it really is freddy's character actually
has a child of his own
he has a stepdaughter named millicent
played by actress jayden triplett
what about millicent's mom we're not too
sure what her deal is but according to
the promo trailer
freddie is in no place to date so who
knows
another newcomer is lacey mosley who
will be taking on the role of carly's
new best friend harper
as for the premise of the series well
that's caught up with the times as well
when icarly first aired carly was the
original influencer on the cutting edge
with her web series but this time
we're getting the reality of carly in
2021 we're talking about
all the new technologies we know and
love now they love us
yeah filters reactions and a whole new
host of emojis
bringing the web series into the modern
digital age i think you can shoot me
using that filter that makes my cheek
bones all
time really has flown by and the
nostalgia
is real it's so exciting to see where
all these actors have gone in their
lives and we can't
wait to see their characters come back
as grown-ups
which character are you most looking
forward to seeing in the reboot
you